nous vivons en ce moment une situation
de crise cette crise découle du
réchauffement climatique de l'épuisement
des ressources de la perte de la
biodiversité et de l'augmentation
démographique et aujourd'hui nous la
subissons à travers une crise sanitaire
cette crise provoque en nous de la peur
peur pour notre espace vital et peur de
ne plus retrouver le contact à la nature
notre mission consiste à enclencher la
transition écologique des villes et des
territoires
tout changement commence dans la tête
c'est pourquoi il est important
d'élaborer une vision et un récit
d'évolution nous vous invitons à
percevoir une agglomération penser en
quartier tourner sur son paysage
ressources connectés et distribué
favorisant le partage et les communs
cette vision est à construire avec les
acteurs et actrices du territoire ses
habitants et habitantes ces
entrepreneurs ces philosophes et même
ses médecins
en somme il est essentiel de partir des
micros échelle pour faire émerger une
image collective d'un territoire donné
le processus est alors participatif
créatif et contextuelle la philosophie
des commun est une valeur essentielle
elle permet l'entr'aide le partage tout
en réduisant les besoins en énergie et
en espace cette philosophie peut être
étudiées à travers trois situations
urbaines périurbaines et de grands
paysages chacune illustre de nouvelles
formes de commun
il est primordial aujourd'hui d'agir sur
le tissu urbain existant car il est
extrêmement consommateurs aussi bien
qu'il soit consiste souvent sous forme
d'îlots il fonctionne de manière
individuelle parcelle par parcelle
appartement par appartement
une reconfiguration de ses espaces doit
voir le jour
imaginez un voisinage basé sur une
organisation collective
ceci permettra de partager les espaces
de planter du végétal et d'accueillir le
vivant d'entreprendre une rénovation
énergétique est d'amener de la mobilité
douce
ces changements s'exprimant tu ce test
et peuvent s'intensifier avec le temps
le projet est évolutif est à l'image de
ses habitantes et habitants
les franges bâti qui sont en contact
avec l'espace agricole ont aussi un rôle
à jouer
ces espaces recouvre trop souvent de
nombreuses zones villas des parkings des
zones commerciales dans une logique dans
tout à la voiture de son côté l'espace
agricole fonctionne de manière
indifférenciée envers les tissus urbains
il est donc fondamental de réconcilier
ces espaces qui aujourd'hui se tourner
le dos cette réconciliation peut se
faire par le biais d'une mise en place
de nouveaux espaces publics et de micros
centralité qui permettront aux
habitantes et habitants de rayonner dans
leur environnement de proximité ainsi
que sous forme de nouvelles
mutualisation spatiale matériel et
immatériel entre agriculteurs
agricultrices et urbain
ces changements pourront être à la fois
le support de projets de densification
qualitative mais également l'impulsion
pour retisser des liens entre la ville
et la campagne
le grand paysage est trop souvent mis
sous cloche
les alpages par exemple parfois
délaissés doivent être réinvestis pour
l'agriculture et réapproprier par les
urbains pour cela il faut se replonger
dans certaines pratiques ancestrales
notamment celles fondées sur les gestion
collective aussi concilier les usages et
la protection de la nature tout en
relançant les filières de production
locale pour rendre le paysage vivant et
au service de sa population
ces espaces pourront alors accueillir de
nouvelles formes de tourisme responsable
expérientiel et de proximité pour
accompagner cette philosophie des
communs il nous faut également
redimensionner le territoire pour de
nouvelles échelles de vie et
d'organisation plus proche de ses
habitantes et habitants
imaginez un archipel de territoires
locaux
ces nouvelles entités correspondent à
une juste et celle qui permettra à
l'individu de se sentir concerné et de
sortir de l'anonymat
dans ces micro territoire de nouveaux
niveaux des décisions et de
responsabilité plus proche des
habitantes et habitants verront le jour
à chaque question correspondre à un
juste niveau de décision
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'échelle de
subsidiarité une meilleure répartition
de la densité sera possible les
habitants et habitantes pourront
profiter de nouvelles centralités proche
de la campagne où tout ce dont on a
besoin se trouvent dans un rayon d'une
demi heure de vélo
l'ensemble de ces transformations repose
sur l'ambition d'une bio régions dans
cette visée le sujet de l'urbanisme
n'est pas uniquement la ville mais bien
le territoire dont elle est le coeur ce
mouvement appelle à l'action et un
activisme en faveur d'une gestion
responsable écologique mettant en
harmonie la culture humaine et
l'environnement naturel le paysage ses
connectivités ses campagnes et son
maillage verts urbains sont considérés
pleinement comme une ressource bien plus
qu'un cadre de vie le paysage est
considéré comme utile vivant et
dynamisée par une production locale
la bio région apporte fraîcheur
biodiversité et résilience à notre
territoire
pour conclure la transition écologique
s'opère au coeur de l'existant et des
situations ordinaires la planification
ne doit pas être exhaustive
elle doit garantir des lieux de liberté
où certaines pratiques et usages
transitoire pourront prendre place dans
le temps et en fonction des besoins des
habitantes des habitants la
reconfiguration de notre environnement
incorpore donc la multifonctionnalité et
la réversibilité
inspirons-nous des écosystèmes naturels
qui interagissent tu es ce qu
construisent chaque élément doit remplir
plusieurs fonctions et chaque fonction
est rempli par plusieurs éléments les
contrées ressources réenchante
l'existant pour faire émerger de
nouveaux modes de vie et un
fonctionnement qui ne nuisent pas à
notre environnement
[Musique]
les postures de gestion collective et
raisonnée des ressources liées au projet
participatif font émerger de nouvelles
nature de projet simple fonctionnel et
porteur de sens aujourd'hui il nous faut
partager cette vision avec les
territoires et trouver les bons outils
pour agir vous proposons d'associer les
deux bouts du processus actuel les
visions communes qui pose l'ambition les
valeurs et le dispositif spatial
cohérent et la mise en oeuvre qui permet
d'engager des expériences de réaliser
des projets pilotes pour faire évoluer
les pratiques le cadre légal et
administratif la transition écologique
et les changements nécessaires à
impulser sont à élaborer de suite et
ensemble